I think the most important thing in the
debate which by the way we all welcome a
debate about the BBC this is a really
precious organization the most important
thing is we don't lose the fact that the
BBC is part of what makes Britain
Britain the BBC is their kind of
creative power house it's a cultural
powerhouse both for the UK to the world
but also within the UK and what I hope
is there are those you can see in the
green paper published today who may want
to diminish the BBC marginalize the BBC
make the BBC much smaller but why I
believe strongly that the British public
have got to be involved in this debate
is because I don't believe that's what
the British public wants and the British
public in the end of the people who pay
for us the government is saying you are
part of the public sector the public
sector across the board NHS everywhere
else is being squeezed and the BBC
shouldn't be an exception to that do you
agree with that I can absolutely see
that when the public sector is being
squeezed that actually we've got to do
our bit as well I understand that
completely but when I don't believe is
that the British public who in the end
pay for us who are our shareholders the
licence fee payers want a BBC that's
diminished or smaller or but doesn't do
anybody so great also the scouts at all
right well you know but but but but the
voice of the people you know we are a
unique public service in the sense that
46 million people who pay for us use us
each day we're in people's homes were
part of their lives apart and what makes
Britain Britain and what I care about is
that their voice is heard in this debate
their voices heard about the shape and
the scale of the BBC that they want and
what they tell us by the way when we ask
them is they want a BBC that of course
entertains as well as informs and
educator I mean the Scotch to take one
example they say they want a bigger
slice of the pie take it away from the
centers here in London well everybody
says they're like a bigger slice of the
pie and move this around or whatever
what I care about is that the BBC is a
national institution it's something that
people care passionately about as soon
as you go away from this country people
say we'd like a BBC and it's part of the
fabric of what makes Britain Britain I
don't want that to be diminished or lost
i don't think the public want that you
also caused by definition you're a mead
company your communications company you
can lobby on your own behalf I mean how
far do you think you should be prepared
to go for example was it a mistake to
lobby people like Michael Palin and
Annie Nightingale to sign that letter to
the Telegraph and we've got to be
careful of course about how we make our
case but I make no apologies for
standing up for what I believe which is
a BBC which is a great national icon
it's something we all believe in and let
me tell you one of the heartwarming and
reassuring things has been over the past
few months how many people from all
sorts of walks of life have come to me
and said you know we want to speak up
for the BBC because we believe BBC i
mean 'animal salad should you be asking
people who you're paying one way or
another to write letters on your money
does anything they don't want to do the
notion that I or anyone else at all say
today and her getting nervous when the
baby come on and you you've worked with
enough artists to know and others to
know but no one does anything that want
to do the fact that people like Judi
Dench and others say they believe in the
BBC they believe in this cultural and
creative strength of the BBC I think is
a real big plus for us and can I say
there are lots more people in other
sorts of communities who also want a
strong BBC what about things like some
MPs are complaining that they've been
sent DVDs by the BBC saying how
marvelous the BBC is is that good
spending my license money I i think it
is and I'll let me putting this to this
argument because the people who often
who are in Parliament making decisions
about the BBC are often the last people
to see some of the quality of the things
that we do so yeah we do send DVDs out
about dramas that we're particularly
proud of and there are many of those or
documentaries we're proud of our
entertainment programs I think this is
him this is an important part of us
making sure that when they make their
decisions it's informed on the quality
of the output I mean if everyone though
is public money that's what makes it
different in a sense them from others
doing that and you know you're courting
a double bond are you really look I
think you can make life really
complicated I think it's actually simple
which is this is an organization i
profoundly believe in it's a creative
organization it's an important part of
what makes Britain Britain and we've got
to stand up for it ok let's just